الجميع مشاهدينا دائما يسعى للترويح عن
نفسه لكن ما ان نذكر التسليه والترفيه حتى
تبدا الاله الحاسبه بالعمل الكل يبحث عن
التسليه لكن بضمان ان تكون امنه حتى لا
تؤثر في النهايه على الموازنه الشهريه
الماليه وتكسر الجيبه ولو يصير عندك فقر
دم بجيبك اليمين لكن كيف يمكن تقدير ما
تحتاجه من المال لاجل تحقيق رفاهيه وحياه
غير مضجره هل هناك طرق لتامين تسليه غير
مكلفه الاهم من ذلك كيف نضع هذه الميزانيه
كما قلنا في البدايه يراويه لاجل حياه
صحيه مليئه بالسعاده ارجوكم اعطونا الخلطه
السحريه
صح اكيد
احنا سالنا الناس على فكره في السعوديه كم
تنفق عاده على مشاويرك الترفيهيه شهريا
خلينا نشوف قديش قول
[موسيقى]
مصاريفي الترفيهيه الشهريه بتكون ما بين
3000 الى 5000 حقيقتين تقريبا المصروفات
الشهريه
[موسيقى]
شهريا تقريبا من 500 الى 700 شهريه تقريبا
المصاريف الشهريه تكون
الا على
[موسيقى]
مطاعم ترفيه الف ريال تقريبا والله كثيرة
لو حسبتها تقريبا ثلاث ارباع الراتب يروح
مصاريف شهريه ترفيهيه لانه
التطلعات كثيره التوجهات كثيره
كمان الواحد يحب انه يكون شغوف انه يشوف
البرامج الترفيهيه التثقيفيه وكلها تضم
دائره واحده
متوسط تقريبا من 2000 الى 3000 ريال
تقريبا المتوسط فيها
معنى لا مشاهدينا في الاستوديو داني
ابراهيم خبير خدمات التنميه الاعمال
وتعليم المالي اهلا بك معنا في صباح
العربي
غيره وغيره كيف بدنا نقدر نضبط هاي
الميزانيه وقديش المفروض تكون من نسبه
الراتب الشهري بشكل عام او نسبتها من
الراتب الشهري طبعا انا بحب اخذ خطوه الى
الخلف ونحكي في الاساسيات من مبادئ
الاداره الماليه الذاتيه
جيده ان نقوم بالتخطيط ليس الفكره ان
نتوقف عن المصروف ومن الاساسيات يعني هو
الصرف على الالتزامات الاساسيه عندما نقوم
بالتخطيط ننظر الى مقدار الدخل ننظر الى
التزاماتنا التي لا يمكن
يعني التفا عليها ايجار المنزل
اساسيات او اي التزامات عقديه قرض قرض
سكني الى اخره
وبعدين مصاريف البيت الجاريه اللي هي بكون
احيانا تختلف من عائله لعائله او من شهر
لشهر
وتخطيط للمصاريف وموعيده المدى ومهم
بالنسبه للترفيه يعني انا لاحظت
بالمشاركين البعض اعت رقم مؤشر جيد لبعض
قال لا اعلم فالافضل لا اعلم
يمكن كل المعاش يعني فالافضل انه انا يعني
خطه كل شيء بما فيها لازم يكون في عندي
جزء للتوفير والتوفير هو بحد ذاته هو اداه
تخطيط ما لانه انا بوفر لاصرف ممكن لاعمل
رحله بس حجمها كبير
انا عندي مثلا دائما بعض الاسر عندها
المشكله الكبرى في الصيف وهي السفر وهذا
ما يكسر الميزانيه ايضا هو جانب ترفيهي
كيف ممكن ان اخطط لهذا الميزانيه يعني
بدءا من انه والله سواء سعر صرف الدولار
او الليره او ايا كان الى انتهاء بتاجير
السياره وغيره والسكن ولا
التضخم يعني خلينا نحطه على جنب لانه هو
الحاله الخاصه
مثل ما تفضلت يعني لذلك حكينا بالتخطيط
والتخطيط يفضل يكون على ست شهور وعاده انا
يعني حتى ربما الواحد من الادوات او
الخطوات المهمه متابعه دخل والصرف لانه مع
الوقت مع المراقبه بنتبه وين مثلا ممكن
انا في عندي حريه حركه لانه مثل ما قلنا
في الالتزامات الاساسيه
فلما بقول بعد ست اشهر عندي هذا المصروف
الكبير بلش اوفر له بشكل شهري بسيط بوصل
لعنده انا مرتاح يعني التوفير دائما مو
للتوفير بعيد الامد مع انه مهم بس في
توفير
قمنا بشراء تذاكر السفر من قبل بوقت يعني
لما بنوصل لموعد السفر بنكون اصلا دفعناهم
قبل ما ينتهي وقتنا نسبه النسبه اللازم
احطها للترفيه من ما تبقى من المرتب بعد
ما نشيل كل المصاريف الضروريه والاساسيه
يعني رقم يذكر مع اني انا ما بحب هذا
الاسلوب لانه بتذكر انه هي حاله شخصيه
لانه في عائله ممكن
تستطيع تدفع 2030% هو الرقم بيقولوا خمسه
لعشره في المئه خمسه الى عشره في الميه من
الدخل بس خمسه
بالنسبه لك بعشرين الف بالشهر يعني طيب
شكرا جزيلا
ابراهيم الخبير في اخر
تنميه الاعمال والتعليم شكرا جزيلا لك
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات